things just keep getting worse for joe
biden the president has lots of
challenges as we all know but probably
his most significant political challenge
is that he can't speak very well in
politics you need to speak that's how
you do politics biden used to speak
pretty well just fine but now he's old
and senile and he doesn't speak very
well and he's blaming it on a childhood
stutter that disappeared for 70 years
but we all know the problem is just that
he's lost a step so this is a problem
for him but it is not insurmountable
from the 2020 campaign up until now joe
biden has generally avoided speaking
he's avoided taking questions from the
press he's had everything laid out in
the teleprompter even that doesn't help
him very much
he's let his press secretary jen saki
do the talking for him
it's worked out
about as well as could be expected
now jen saki has left that job
karine jean-pierre is in
and it turns out the new girl has the
same problem that joe biden has
president
twitter account posted the other day you
want to bring down inflation let's make
sure the wealthiest corporations pay
their fair share
how does raising taxes on corporations
reduce inflation
um
so
are you talking about a specific tweet
he tweeted you want to bring down
inflation let's make sure the wealthiest
corporations pay their fair share
look you know we have talked about
we have talked about this this past year
about making sure that the wealthiest
among us are paying their fair share
and that is important to do and that is
something that
you know the president has been you know
working on uh every day when we talk
about inflation and lowering costs and
so it's very important uh that uh you
know as we're seeing costs rise as we're
talking about how to you know uh you
know build a america that's safe that's
equal for everyone it doesn't leave
everyone behind that is an important
part of that as well
if
if charlie kelly from it's always sunny
in philadelphia we're trying to answer
this question he would not have been
less coherent than corrine jean-pierre
here this is so embarrassing it's
embarrassing on so many levels one she's
completely unprepared she didn't even
know about this tweet that joe biden
sent which obviously is going to come up
because it was such an opening for the
conservatives
the way we're going to bring down
inflation is by raising the taxes on
corporations there is
almost
no connection whatsoever between raising
taxes on corporations and inflation
these are completely separate issues so
not only was she unprepared she didn't
know what the tweet was was that was
going to be referenced but second she
didn't have an answer she actually just
said she goes oh yes well we we uh
raising taxes on corporations is
something that we have talked about
because of because we want to raise
taxes on corporations and so we and
filibuster and bird law and it's it's
like a sketch from always sunny
it's a it's a long answer i have to play
you the rest of it
but how does raising taxes on
corporations lower the cost of gas the
cost of used car the cost of food for
everyday americans so look i think we
encourage those who have done very well
right especially those who care about
climate change uh to support a fair
attack tax code that doesn't change that
doesn't charge manufacturers workers
cops builders a higher percentage of
their earnings that the most fortunate
people in our nation and not let this
that stand in the way of reducing energy
costs and fighting this existential
problem if you think about that as an
example and to support basic collective
bargaining rights as well right that's
also important but look it is you know
by not if without having a fair tax code
which is what i'm talking about then all
every like manufacturing workers cops
you know it's not fair for them to have
to pay higher taxes than the folks that
who are who are who are not paying taxes
at all
uh korean we're going to just try it
again how does this one thing raising
taxes on corporations how does that have
anything to do with the totally
unrelated different thing
uh
climate change
climate change workers babies
freedom
equality unions
are you glitching out or is there is
there a bug in your system somehow
absolutely
pathetic cringe inducing i almost i
almost feel bad for her
except that this is her job
when she was hired when when a korean
jump year was hired jen saki said that
karine was a great choice because she's
a black lesbian that was the first thing
jen saki said she said it's so great
that korean got this job because she's a
black lesbian and for some reason it's
really important that a black lesbian
serve as press secretary
i couldn't tell you why now of course i
have
nothing against black lesbians more
power to black lesbians
it would seem to me
that before the white house offered her
the job of presidential spokesman they
might have considered making sure that
the woman could actually speak this is a
perfect encapsulation of the democrats
most pressing challenge today
they have no idea what their message is
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show climate change
filibuster
workers unions i don't know i've got a
lot more to say actually than karine
john pierre does my favorite comment
yesterday is from hashtag nolstradamus
who says
joe biden says
i'm trying to carefully say this
because he's trying to remember what
they told him to say that's true
yesterday when we played that clip of
joe biden
launching this new phrase into the
culture ultra maga when he was trying to
drop this phrase
he took a moment he took a beat and he
said well the problem is these uh hold
on i want to say this carefully
ultra maggot republicans
that he he actually was doing exactly
what you're describing he was taking a
beat there
because he knew that he had to drop this
line and it was focus group for six
months and this was going to be the new
democrat slogan and he couldn't quite
remember it because he's not so fast on
his feet i sort of excuse the 80 year
old president who was never the
brightest bulb in the pack for for
having that little mental pause there i
i really don't don't excuse the young
press secretary who's supposed to be
much much better at this all right if
you want something done right
sometimes you got to do it yourself
which is why you got to check out rock
auto right now go to rockauto.com write
knowles in their hatted you hear about
us box there is a very good chance that
whatever car or truck or minivan you
drive has appreciated considerably over
the last year well make sure you take
care of that vehicle you got to go to
rockauto.com
instead of going to the brick and mortar
store waiting online
you get up to the front they don't have
the part there's just too many parts to
stock and then you wait you drive back
you waste all your time you pay a lot of
extra money
go to rockauto.com these guys are the
real deal they're totally reliable they
have been on this show big supporters of
this show
basically from day one okay so i love
them for that already and then when i
their reliability and their loyalty
supporting us you see that same
reliability and loyalty supporting auto
parts customers online for 20 years
they've got a super easy to navigate
catalog the website's so simple to use
you know even i can do it they've got
the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers they don't have any
gimmicks or anything like that go to
rockauto.com for your auto parts write
knowles can wles in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you also by the way check out
jonathan isaac's new book why i stand
published with daily wire books you know
daily wire is taking over every single
industry in the entire country well we
got this great book with jonathan isaac
it's got important messages about faith
about courage that everyone can benefit
from so go check out jonathan isaac's
book today you can order it wherever
great books are sold
the democrats cannot stay on message
they don't get it eric swalwell just
proved this you remember eric swalwell
he is best known for his incontinence on
a cnn camera and for dropping out very
very early of the 2020 presidential
primary and for sleeping with a chinese
spy eric swalwell tweeted out yesterday
in an attempt to exploit the buffalo
massacre that the shooting that took
place over the weekend he wanted to
exploit it for his own political
purposes and so he tweeted out quote
my four-year-old just facetimed to ask
what i'm doing to help the people of
buffalo and why did the bad man do this
absolutely gutting this cannot be
his normal i guess he is there's a typo
there it's time to ban assault weapons
hashtag and gun violence
never mind for a second that swalwell is
using
such a
deeply insincere and ridiculous
tweet format people make fun of this
they said my three-year-old just called
me and he asked me daddy how do we how
do we reconcile deontological and
consequentialist ethics and i said son
son i don't know and then everyone in
the tsa line applauded my 18 month old
baby just texted me and he said uh daddy
uh how do we how do we resolve the
riemann hypothesis and i said i don't
know sunny
let let me let me go visit your
princeton math class and then everyone
at harvard applaud it and this is the
kind of format that everyone makes fun
of it's become a meme and eric swalwell
sent this out sincerely as though his
four-year-old was was facetiming him and
asking him about these things but but
even worse for swalwell
he's not on message he doesn't realize
that while of course the democrats are
exploiting the mass shooting to advance
their own political agenda they're not
doing it on gun control right now
they're
the way that the democrats are
exploiting the the tragedy is to try to
incite a race war the way that the
democrats are currently
exploiting the tragedy is to try to get
tucker carlson fired that's what they're
they're they are going to get to gun
control that is going to happen but
they're not on it yet and so swalwell
he's not even on on the the right moment
of of the messaging of the propaganda of
the way that the democrats are
exploiting this tragedy really
embarrassing though not surprising eric
swalwell is not ready for prime time
megan kelly our friend megan kelly
just threw her hands in the air she was
so furious at the way that the democrats
have been exploiting this tragedy she
asked a simple question she said hey
before all the political maneuvering
can we just take a couple minutes to
mourn
some in the media
have been quick to point fingers and
even place blame
on our friend and very popular fox news
host tucker carlson it's outrageous it's
wrong both factually and morally
why do we have to go to that place
immediately on these stories why can't
we spend two
minutes mourning the people who are dead
and trying to understand that we have
insane people in this country we have
lunatics
it's a huge country
we're not going to be able to get rid of
them all
it infuriates me people have to inject
their politics into everything and this
guy had a racist manifesto there's no
question that doesn't make it tucker
carl's fault just stop it
just stop it
megan is so good at these
sorts of stories telling these stories
especially with this kind of uh
level of tragedy to it and really
conveying
what happened and who these people were
and she's really really good at that
but in answer to her question can't we
take two minutes to no we can't
we can't the the democrats will not let
us do that
the reason that we can't just take two
minutes to to mourn before this becomes
political is because the only reason
that the media are having us talk about
this at all
is to attack conservatives that's the
whole point
now when you want to protect yourself
and your home and your family you got to
check out ring right now go to ring.com
knowles when it comes to home security
are you an amateur or are you a pro
now you know i love rings video doorbell
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door wherever you are in the home
outside the home you know i love that
you know i love ring alarm this is that
award-winning home security system lets
you control for freeze fly fire flood
say that five times fast the bad guys
you can protect your home wherever you
are whether you're in the home outside
the home but have you gone pro
because ring alarm pro is being hailed
by cnet as a giant leap for home
security when you go pro you protect not
just your physical home but your digital
home your virtual home it includes
protection for your wi-fi network you
live so much of your life online you got
to protect you can't just protect the
the brick and mortar you got to protect
the virtual life too i love ring truly
it makes me feel much safer much better
whether i'm at home whether sweet little
lease in the baby you're at home whether
we're all on vacation go to ring.com
knowles that's ring.com slash knowles be
like me go pro become a pro ring.com
knowles
megan kelly says can't we just mourn for
two minutes before we politicize a
tragedy like the shooting in buffalo the
answer is no because
if
if the shooting in buffalo
did not fit the predetermined democrat
narrative if the shooting in buffalo did
not serve to advance the democrat
political agenda we just would not be
talking about it maybe you would have
heard about it it was a really horrific
attack maybe you would have heard about
it for a day or two but it would have
just disappeared we wouldn't still be
taught it would be like the waukesha
killing where a
black racist drove his car into a crowd
and killed a lot of white people during
a christmas parade not that long ago
just just what at the end of november
and you would have heard about it for a
day or two and then it would have just
disappeared because it wouldn't have
served to advance the media's and the
political establishment's agenda
it would have been like the new york
city subway shooting
the new york city subway shooting was a
black racist who went down there and
shot lots and lots of people so over 20
people i think were injured in that
shooting
but it was a news story for a day or two
and then it just disappeared had the
shooter been white it would have been a
news story
until today it would have been a new
story for six months same goes for
waukesha so in in just a very technical
answer to megan's question no you won't
get the two minutes to mourn
we wouldn't we wouldn't be talking about
it
the whole it's sick it's sick and it's
really sad that this is the way the
media work
but
the only reason
that this is in the news
it's not the human tragedy
it's not the the sorrow that everyone
feels for the victims families and for
the victims themselves it's not the
anger that people feel at the shooter
it is solely to be used as a cudgel to
attack the political opponents of the
media and of the political class
there are there are really big shootings
really awful crimes committed all of the
time
that you will never hear of
they might not
they might not be quite the gruesome
scale of what happened in buffalo but
some of them can be pretty close did you
hear about the story of this was just a
few months ago in
los angeles
of a woman celebrating her birthday
being targeted and killed in an ambush
where at least four people were killed i
think more people were shot
this woman's family it was a birthday
party and just all gunned down right
right i guarantee you you never heard of
that story
because that doesn't advance a political
agenda did you hear the story this one
was crazy this happened in milwaukee
just uh
gosh just a few days ago i think what
the press release came out on may 13th
it's may 17th right now where how many
people
that's eight
16 people were shot
16 people shot
and then
oh maybe even more than that it was a
mass mass shooting in in milwaukee you
didn't hear about that of course you
didn't hear about that
it doesn't advance a political agenda
so that's that's what this is about and
if you want to understand the national
conversation and all the calls that are
coming from washington you need to
recognize
that
the the only stories that will ever even
get past the threshold to become a topic
of national conversation are the ones
that permit the establishment to attack
conservatives so they're going after
the tucker carlson in particular now but
republicans generally
after the media have determined that the
story advances their agenda then you get
joe biden going in and saying okay i'm
going to go to buffalo
he wouldn't go to waukesha he said it
required too many presidential assets
there's no way he could make it to talk
to the victims and the victims families
but he can go to buffalo
because waukesha doesn't help him
politically and buffalo does help him
politically then after you get the
political establishment going in and
defending it then you get the court
jester conservatives
enter liz cheney right on cue liz cheney
tweets out quote the house gop
leadership has enabled white nationalism
white supremacy and anti-semitism
history has taught us what that what
begins with words ends and far worse gop
leaders must renounce and reject these
views and those who hold them
so notice liz cheney is not saying let's
pray for the victims liz cheney is not
doing anything to help the victims
families in buffalo she's not doing
anything productive she is just doing
exactly what the media and the democrat
political establishment are doing namely
exploiting a tragedy to attack her
political opponents and her political
opponents are the republicans even
though she's got an r next to her name
she's not really a conservative she's
not really a republican she is a court
jester conservative her job is to
pretend to be a conservative to pretend
to put up opposition but then on every
crucial matter to cave to the dominant
liberal establishment that's her whole
utility that's her whole point
she she's just there to legitimize the
liberals and the democrats her real
opponents her real enemies are the
republicans and specifically now they're
all going after tucker carlson the
current narrative the current message is
that tucker carlson has has spread what
they now dubbed the great replacement
conspiracy theory
and by tucker carlson embracing the
great replacement conspiracy theory he
is responsible for the killing in
buffalo that's the narrative and it's
being advanced by democrats it's being
advanced by the media but i repeat
myself and it's being advanced by liz
cheney but i repeat myself again what is
the great replacement conspiracy theory
the great replacement conspiracy theory
so-called is that democrats use
immigration policy to
change the american demographics and
increase their political power that's
the grand conspiracy theory and if it
doesn't sound like a conspiracy theory
it obviously is not democrats have
bragged about this for many years for
most of my
life for my entire adult life democrats
have printed article after article
saying republicans are demographically
doomed immigration is going to kill the
republicans because the republicans rely
disproportionately on the votes of white
men
and so as the white percentage of the
population decreases then republicans
electoral power is going to decrease
and this means haha democrats are going
to be in power forever it's not just the
new york times that has supported this
though they have
it's not just msnbc cnn it's not just
all the liberal media that have embraced
this theory joe biden himself embraced
this theory
not so long ago
so there's a second thing in that black
box
an unrelenting stream of immigration
non-stop
non-stop
folks like me who were
caucasian of european descent
for the first time in 2017 will be in an
absolute minority in the united states
of america
absolute minority
fewer than 50 percent of the people in
america from then and on
will be
white european stock
that's not a bad thing
that's as a source of our strength
there it is that's the whole conspiracy
theory if you're going to attack tucker
carlson for embracing this crazy wild
conspiracy theory then you need to
attack joe biden for embracing the same
crazy wild conspiracy theory and you
have to attack the entire democrat
establishment and the media
establishment because they're the ones
who have bragged about this for decades
too
now some of what joe biden said there is
not factually correct he said
in the very first part of that clip that
throughout the entirety of american
history going back to the 18th century
we've had a steady stream an unrelenting
stream of immigration that's not really
true we've actually had huge periods of
american history where there has been
relatively very little immigration and
then really starting in 1965 when the
democrats led by ted kennedy completely
changed the immigration rules and opened
it up to a flood of of new immigration
that's really when when things started
to change and really move in the
direction of democrats political favor
but what does joe biden say there he
says
we're going to have because of all this
immigration
we're going to
shrink the white percentage of the
population and this is a really good
thing
and it and if you're a democrat
there is at least good reason to think
that's true i actually don't think it's
quite as simple as that because right
now you're seeing huge numbers of
hispanic voters moving to the gop just
within the past four four years or so
and really starting with trump but then
accelerating in more recent years so
there's a chance that democrats get what
they wish for and it and it doesn't look
like what they were hoping it would be
there's a chance that actually
republicans are going to get some
benefit here as well but certainly the
democrats think that that is the case
that's what they've been writing about
that's what joe biden's talking about
he's saying that's a source of our
strength he might be
pretending to talk about american
strength but he's certainly talking
about democrat strength at the very
least he's saying because these
immigrants are more likely to identify
as republicans than or as democrats
rather then
that will be a great source of strength
that'll change the country and that's
our big win
so that the democrats now are exploiting
the tragedy to attack tucker carlson for
quoting joe biden's own words back to
him
they'll move on after this they will
exploit the tragedy for gun control they
will exploit the tragedy to go after all
sorts of other people
but
but that is the point that is all
they're looking at i have a piece up at
the daily wire today
on how how to exploit a shooting to
blame it on your political opponents
because if you i read the shooter's
manifesto
if you look in the shooter's manifesto
you can find something
so you can find a line
to make it seem as though the shooter is
on the other side
whether you're on the left or the right
you can find a line or two lines or ten
lines to make it seem like the shooter
is on the left he says he's on the left
he says he's an authoritarian leftist
but you can find lines that make it seem
like he's on the right
he said he's moved much further to the
right
you can find all of these lines
you can score points ah ding point for
the right wing oh here we go score one
point on the tragedy for the left wing
but it's pointless and it's especially
pointless for conservatives because the
whole
media apparatus right now
is using this
for that one purpose and that one
purpose only that is to attack
you
now
when you want to be responsible unlike
our irresponsible media when you want to
be responsible it's very important to
get your affairs in order which is why
you got to check out epic will right now
go to epicwill.com use promo code
knowles the foundation of your family
what do you want it to be do you want it
to be what some other guy believes what
some other guy thinks is best or what
you believe your faith your beliefs
if something god forbid should happen to
you or your spouse who do you trust to
instill those beliefs in your children
do you think that it's the same person
that the state necessarily would assign
them to if you do not have a will in
place you have no say in the future of
your kids let that sink in for a second
if you're single and you don't think you
need a will you could not possibly be
more wrong a will allows you to
establish advanced directive medical
power of attorney so we're talking about
what happens to you do you really want
to leave the burden of deciding life
support or not to a randomly assigned
family member or a close friend i don't
think so a will allows you to clearly
communicate to your loved ones what your
wishes are regarding your health if you
have not made one yet you are not alone
i actually just finalized mine last week
we are going to make it really easy for
you at epicwill.com use code knowles
love these guys really proud to partner
with them i'm glad they're protecting
daily wire let them protect you as well
epicwheel.com promo code knulls that's
how easy it is secure your future in as
little as five minutes get a complete
will package starting at 119 bucks with
promo code nulls you'll get
10 off epic will.com most important five
minutes you will spend today
also leading up to the two year
anniversary of george floyd's death and
the radical worldwide repercussions that
followed candace owens has taken her
bold lens to the people and places that
ignited the violent and racially divided
aftermath join candace as she goes
beyond what you've been told by the
media to bring the truth to light and
expose
the greatest lie ever told the trailer
for this explosive documentary drops
tonight 8 pm central on candace's show
the greatest lie ever told george floyd
and the rise of blm is only available to
daily wire members so subscribe today at
thegreatestlie.com
tune in tonight to be the first to catch
the exclusive trailer we'll be right
back with a lot more
the future of the gop is playing out in
pennsylvania right now
we've come down to the pennsylvania
senate primary there are three top
candidates
dr oz the the t the turkish tv show
daytime talk show guy
david mccormick who's former ceo of
bridgewater he's a hedge fund guy kind
of a business republican
he was an official i think in treasury
during the bush administration and kathy
barnett who was a little bit of a wild
card she was a military veteran
political commentator she's less well
known than the other two guys
seems to be the more conservative
candidate more to the right
but less well-known she's really surged
in recent weeks and now would appear to
be
among the top two candidates
according to a survey from susquehanna
napoleon research released just
yesterday
dr oz has 28 percent of likely
republican voters kathy barnett has 27
of likely republican voters
and
mccormick i don't have his exact numbers
here but i think he's fallen
fairly significantly behind
this race
you know i don't really do endorsements
in republican primaries i don't live in
pennsylvania the voters there can decide
unless there are all sorts of nefarious
election maneuvers to lots of mules and
things like that to misrepresent the
will of the voters although i don't
think you would see that in a gop
primary i think you'd be more likely to
see that in a general election so it's
up to the republican voters of
pennsylvania to decide
the point of this election is to see how
far the overton window has shifted
i think if you just looked on the issues
here
dr oz would be the furthest left
candidate in the i mean dr oz has
endorsed abortion he's complained about
pro-life laws around the country very
very recently dr oz has seemed to
encourage
transgender transition for minors i mean
the guy does not seem really
conservative at all then you've got
david mccormack david mccormick seems
like a business republican he on the
social issues is to the left he i think
he submitted a brief to the court in
defense of redefining marriage in the
obergefell case so socially
he would seem to be
more to the left i'm not sure that he
would be as far to the left as dr oz
and the kind of business economic issues
he seems broadly what you would expect
from a more establishment republican
type figure
and then you've got
kathy barnett
kathy barnett seems to check all of the
boxes on the conservative issue so if
you're just voting on the issues
probably you're gonna and you're a
conservative you're probably gonna vote
for kathy barnett but then there's the
question of electability
this is the this is the old buckley rule
that you should vote for the most right
viable candidate
and so dr oz actually has something to
recommend him here which is that he's a
very famous tv host who's got a lot of
name recognition who is some i guess
more centrist than the other candidates
and pennsylvania is a somewhat blue
state so maybe he's more electable david
mccormick he's a self-funder he's got a
lot of money he's mainstream he's worked
in a kind of centrist administration so
maybe he's more electable kathy barnett
we just don't know we don't know her as
well she doesn't have as much name
recognition there there might be things
in her past there might not be things in
her past we just don't know
that
that's the decision that people are
going to
look at here donald trump endorsed dr oz
sean hannity is all in for dr oz the
sean hannity show has become basically
the dr oz commercial okay
and all right that's their prerogative
ted cruz has gone in for david mccormick
and uh this was before the kathy barnett
surge but cruz seems to be for mccormick
kurt schlichter who's a pretty rock
ribbed conservative columnist kurt just
went in he said look i'm not saying
mccormick's the most conservative guy
but he's a guy who can win i don't think
kathy barnett can win in the general
mccormick i think can so i'm in for for
david mccormick i interviewed kathy
barnett the interview came out on sunday
she's a very very impressive candidate
as far as i can tell whether or not
she's electable in a general i just
don't know
i just don't know i'm not i'm not as
familiar with the voters of pennsylvania
i'm not as familiar with those dynamics
now the voters know her better than i do
because she's been going door-to-door
for many months that is what's playing
out and we're going to get an answer
very very soon how far has the overton
window shifted if the this election were
happening 10 years ago there's no
question mccormick would be the choice
there's there's absolutely no question
dr oz would probably be laughed out of
the room kathy barnett would probably be
considered too right-wing and mccormick
would be the guy
but things have changed a lot and if it
were 20 years ago oh there's no question
mccormick would be the guy
and maybe he still would be
today
but maybe
the conservatives
have moved more conservative maybe the
whole country has moved more
conservative maybe kathy barnett is
there that's what we're watching frankly
it's it's more interesting to me
even than
the individual candidates and who gets
to win where is the country moving where
is the momentum
you look right now
one of the most popular governors in
america certainly the most popular
governor for republicans but one of the
most popular period who is it's ron
desantis
ron desantis is a conservative he's a
real conservative he's not one of these
cut it down the middle try to split the
baby guys ron desantis anytime a
conservative issue pops up in the
culture ron desantis is there doing
something about it in florida ron
desantis just signed a bill in florida
to make it illegal to protest outside of
someone's home desantis signed the
florida house bill 1571 just yesterday
under the law
law enforcement officers must issue a
warning to protesters to disperse if
they don't officers can arrest them
the violators will be prosecuted and
punished as second-degree misdemeanors
this law will go into effect on october
1st so
this obviously is in reaction to the
protests outside of the homes of the
supreme court justices
i have this sense now
that ron desantis just all day he's just
on twitter
and he's waiting to see
whatever the news story is and you say
okay here's the boom news story is
there's protests outside of the judge's
homes okay i need a law get me a law
right now i'm going to sign it we're
going to make this illegal here we it's
now illegal the news story is there's a
plus-size swimsuit model on sports
illustrated okay so get me a law there
will not be plus-sized swimsuit models
in florida okay that's banned we're
getting the the story is that eric
swalwell's pushing for gun control okay
we are in the state of florida we are
going to mandate that every baby has an
ar-15 yeah especially now because
abortion is threatening the babies now
more than ever that's what we're doing
in florida and he's so
freaking good at this the guy is in the
news every day because every national
issue and especially every issue that
matters to conservatives he's there
doing something about it shows you the
advantage that governors have over
senators and congressmen and cabinet
officials in terms of running for
president
because senators right now you might
have the most rock-ribbed reliable
conservative senator in the world but if
the senators are in the minority if
there's a democrat in the white house
the senators can't do very much
congressmen certainly can't do very much
and cabinet officials former cabinet
officials can't do anything at all other
than give speeches but the governors can
go in there
and pass whatever whatever the the bill
is
whatever the cause du jour is
eric swalwell tweets about how his
four-year-olds facetiming okay we've got
a new law in florida four-year-olds are
not allowed to face time you've got to
be five years old to facetime that's
what we're doing in florida that's what
we're doing for america and it's a very
effective it's a very effective way to
get your name into the news cycle to put
yourself up in the pecking order when
you're looking at at
the presidency
and it shows you where that overton
window's shifted by the way folks if you
had told me five years ago
that education was going to be the
biggest issue or one of the biggest
issues in 2022-2024
if you told me that getting lgbt
ideology out of schools was going to be
one of the biggest issues in 2022 2024 i
would have laughed at you i'd have said
that's a conservative pipe dream but
that's not really what's going to happen
and then it did that's
that's the shifting pendulum that's the
shifting overton window how far can it
go by this election cycle by the next
one that remains to be seen
some candidates unlike ron desantis do
not have very good political instincts
i'm thinking in particular i'm thinking
of the anti-desantis the opposite of ron
desantis namely
beetho o'rourke
loses the run for senate loses the run
for president now he's running for
governor of texas they don't work at the
moment
in which
the pro-life movement is probably at the
height of its influence at the moment in
which the pro-abortion movement is
probably at the absolute lowest point of
its influence among voters and among the
institutions beto o'rourke shows up to
the view to demand no limits on abortion
bye-bye babies whatsoever but i do want
to press further because you're a
progressive hero there are so many
people around the country who admire you
and your leadership do you believe in
any limit limitations on abortion
whether it's the third trimester or up
until even the final months nine months
i think roe versus wade which we should
remind ourselves is still the law of the
land today
is the the
the reference point that i would look to
and
the way i think i can best express this
is that i trust women we should all
trust women to make their own decisions
that are in their best interest for
themselves for their health care and for
their future that's the way it's been
literally my entire life i'm 49 years
old be 50 this year but that's the way
it should be going forward um but let me
just finish this point super quickly in
in texas under greg abbott's watch a
hundred kids lost their lives last year
in the cps child protective services
system in texas under the care and the
custody of the state of texas if he
cared about life he would have cared
about those kids but he cares about
political points and control and power
over women's body he loves his gun
instead
so pathetic
so weak coming from beto o'rourke if
listen there there is a very sad story
kids died in the foster care system and
if greg abbott really cared about life
he would have killed those kids much
sooner
he wouldn't have let those kids live for
however long they did live he would have
killed them much sooner that's how you
care about life why is he even talking
about the foster carers yeah you find me
a republican who thinks that the foster
care system is just perfect
or thinks that that uh there's there's
no way to improve the foster care give
me a break
i don't know who i don't there's no
republican there's a complete straw man
and if you really cared about no if
listen buddy we're talking about
abortion and your view on abortion is so
hideous morally idiotic and unpopular
that you don't want to talk about
abortion and you want to move on and
talk about foster care okay you want to
talk about foster care let's talk about
foster care
i would love to reform the foster care
system i would love to make it easier
for parents to adopt and less expensive
for parents to adopt in this country i
would love to make it harder for parents
to get divorced in this country i would
love to do all sorts of things that
would help families in america i would
love to change
aspects of our industrial policy i would
love to change aspects of our trade
policy to make it easier to form
families i would love to do all sorts of
stuff
if you want to have oh you don't want to
have that conversation now you're
talking about guns for some reason joy
bayer and we need to talk about gun no
you those are totally separate issues
i'm happy to talk about guns too but
you're all running away from the issue
of abortion because you know that your
position on it namely that you should be
able to kill a baby one minute before
he's born is extremely unpopular and
obviously evil and wrong
so they they keep trying to shift the
goal posts
this guy does not have good instincts
whenever beta or o'rourke issues an
opinion on something if you are an
aspiring politician if you want to be
effective in the political square do the
opposite okay it's just
even regardless of what you think it is
a good bet that whatever beta or work
thinks the opposite is going to be more
politically effective turning now from a
terrible show to a good show from the
view to the joe rogan show joe rogan
expressed last week i meant to get to it
last week we can get to it now his view
on the abortion issue and i think his
view
is actually where a lot of americans are
on the issue joe rogan's view is i'm for
a woman's right to choose but
you know it's just
i just don't like you know i don't like
people telling other people what they
can and can't do but it gets weird when
the baby gets like six months old you
know it gets weird when they're really
really pregnant because in some states
for the longest i don't know what the
rules are now but i know that some
states have late term abortions and
sometimes you need one for medical
reasons right like the woman could die
if she gives birth like it's a decision
that people have to make well if you
look back what was your favorite part of
being a fetus ah
well what was your favorite part of
being three you know should i be able to
shoot you at three because i don't want
to take care of you anymore it's one of
those things it's like i am 100 for a
woman's right to choose
but as a human being just as a just a
person observing things there's a big
difference between a little clump of
cells
and a fetus with eyeball and a beating
heart and for anybody to pretend there's
not is it's
you're not doing any where do you draw
the line right where do you draw the
line yeah yeah that's the question
so joe's view here is
totally understandable i think it's
probably the majority of you in america
it it also is the least coherent view
so it
i think the pro-life view
and even the pro-abortion view you know
the pro-life view which is
if human life has worth it all it has
worth from the very beginning and we
should defend it
that makes sense
the pro-abortion view the the really
honest pro-abortion view which is yes
obviously the baby is a baby obviously
the baby is a human but we want women to
have maximal bodily autonomy and in
order for women to have the same degree
of bodily autonomy as men they need to
be able to kill their kids that's the
view popularized by naomi wolfe it's the
view popularized by that girl who came
on my show last week
that view i think it's ghastly i think
it's evil but i understand it
joe's view
is
it makes less sense but i i can
understand why people come along to it
which is
look i don't want to tell women what to
do i don't i want women to be able to do
whatever they want to do but like come
on it's at a certain point it's
obviously a baby right and it's
obviously wrong to kill babies and when
his guest makes that glib joke what was
your favorite part about being a fetus
joe mocks him for he says oh hahaha i
don't know what's your favorite part
about being three should you be like you
know give me a break man do you remember
being two come on come on that's that's
such a weak argument
but then joe says well there's a huge
difference between a clump of cells and
a
six-month-old baby in the womb but there
there isn't a total difference actually
there it you know the either they i
think that the the big differences here
the big distinguishing features are
are you alive are you a human
i think those are the difference between
alive and not alive the difference
between human and not human are much
bigger differences than say the
difference between having fully formed
hands and not fully formed hands between
having fully formed eyeballs and not
fully formed eyeballs those seem to me
they're differences but those are much
super more superficial differences then
are you alive or are you not alive are
you human or are you not human joe is so
close he's so on the right track here
and he realizes that the pro-abortion
propaganda is bs now the only question
for him and really
you know i think he so expresses popular
views that it's a question for all of
america is are you going to go all the
way with your correct moral intuitions
or are you going to follow them to their
logical conclusion
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth these days
is
six to nine months i think we've agreed
right
so
what were the conspiracy theories
actually covid19 did not arise in nature
but probably had something to do with a
laboratory and and uh public health
funding and that was a crazy conspiracy
theory oh no wait no it turns out it's
true actually the the covid vaccines
they they might have some negative side
effects and they might no no that's not
that's a crazy conspiracy theory okay
it's true the coveted vaccines they
might
they might affect a woman's menstrual
cycle that's not true it's
scientifically impossible it's a total
conspiracy theory oh okay well no never
mind that that actually is true all of
um and i'm just focusing on the
conspiracy theories of the last three
years uh conspiracy theory there might
have been some shenanigans in the 2020
election no no that's crazy that's well
actually look at pennsylvania look at
georgia look at okay right
lots of conspiracy theories turn it so
the craziest one though
and i think i heard alex jones talking
about this some years ago but i've heard
other people talk about it they said
that
older
wealthy elite people
are going to prolong their lives
by
consuming the blood and the vital
liquids of young people it's something
out of a horror movie right it's
something out of a sci-fi dystopian
that's so crazy that's never going to oh
my goodness there's the headline youth
transplants really can slow the aging
process this is from the telegraph
stanford scientists find infusions of
cerebrospinal fluid can regenerate the
brain's memory center
and may help to rejuvenate elderly
bodies
they even acknowledge they say
harvesting the blood and body parts of
the young in the hope of achieving
immortality has long been a familiar
trope in horror novels and conspiracy
theories but as macabre as that sounds
science is beginning to discover that
youth process really can slow down the
aging process
the fountain of youth it seems is youth
itself and so these uh researchers at
stanford are looking at how
if we if we just harvest the young
and then old people who are afraid of
death just take
the vital
life-giving fluids of the young and just
inject them into their own desiccated
bodies that they might get to live a
little bit longer
this seems like a bad idea
doesn't this seem like a bad idea
i think it does this is because of a
delusion
that elites have had since the dawn of
time and every generation that comes up
with it thinks it's brand new which is
hey maybe we can conquer death ourselves
now
i being a christian believe that death
has already been conquered in an eternal
way by jesus christ on the cross
that's not good enough for the libs
that's not good enough for some elites
throughout history even before there was
such a thing as liberalism who who don't
want to face
a bodily death
who want to just live in this world
forget the life of the world to come
forget
the eternity forget in the bosom of
abraham forget you know but the beatific
vision no no they just want to live in
this world forever and they're so afraid
of the lights going out
that they're always looking for the
fountain of youth they're always looking
for some magic elixir they're looking
for radical life extension you see the
silicon valley types talking about this
all the time today and it's just as
silly today as when the pharaohs were
doing it
it's it's not going to work forever and
it's sick it's
it gets to a
an especially pronounced cultural issue
today
which is the refusal of people to grow
up you need to grow up growing up is not
a bad thing
growing up is a very good thing we have
a society of overgrown babies these days
because no one wants to actually grow up
and mature
this is why we have the phrase adulting
when 35 year olds finally figure out how
to pay their bills they say i'm adulting
oh yeah i finally filed my taxes totally
adulting no you should have been doing
that for many years at this point
and now people get married you know much
much later if they do have children at
all they have children much much later
they say i'm adulting because i and and
look
people
suffer from infertility often as a
result of delaying these sorts of things
but very often people will choose not to
get married they'll choose not to have
children and the reason that they'll
choose that is because they want to
continue to go to brunch like they did
when they were 22 years old
they don't they don't want to move on to
the next they're so afraid of using
losing their youth
they want to just sit at home and do all
the things they did as children and not
put those things away you have to put
those things away and it's true i'm not
just beating up on the millennials my
own generation
it's true at the upper end of that
spectrum too sometimes it's time to move
on how can we still have baby boomers as
president actually joe biden's not even
a baby boomer we went backwards we had a
baby boomer president in bill clinton we
had a baby boomer president in george
bush
we had a gen x president in barack obama
then we had a baby boomer president we
went back in donald trump and then we
went back even further if you can
believe it to the generation before the
baby boomers with joe biden
there's no moving on there's no handing
off the i don't even blame the boomers
the millennials don't seem particularly
ready for it and the boomers
have totally messed up the society in
the from the mid to late 20th century
so there are problems all around and i
think a lot of it just gets to not
accepting this fact of time not
accepting this fact of aging not
accepting the fact of death you're going
to die someday that's one of my favorite
twitter accounts is the death reminder
the memento mori you will die someday
in my office at the daily wire i have a
picture the caravaggia print of
caravaggio's painting of saint jerome
who's writing he's translating the bible
and he's got a skull right there the
memento mori you are going to die it's
good to remember that you're going to
die
because that will motivate you to to do
the right thing today to get your
affairs in order it will actually
ironically put you at far greater peace
than if you think that you can live
forever by sucking out the spinal fluid
of young people don't
don't do that folks okay
you're not going to live forever this is
so much of this public health neurosis
and insanity of the last two and three
years now has come because of people's
irrational ridiculous fear of aging and
sickness and dying
a lot before we go to there's just an
important point here misinformation is
being spread on this
uh the white house just tweeted out
when president biden took office
millions were unemployed there was no
vaccine available
in the last 15 months the economy has
created lots and lots of jobs and blah
blah blah
now of course that's fake news that's
misinformation more than three million
americans were fully vaccinated
and more than 18 million
had at least one dose of the vaccine by
the time joe biden was inaugurated joe
biden himself was was vaccinated by the
time he was inaugurated so that was fake
news that was disinformation
is the disinformation governance board
the new ministry of truth are they going
to go after the white house for that i
sincerely doubt it is the white house
ever going to get on message not with a
press secretary like this not with a
democratic party like this which has
nothing which is gasping which is
desperate which is running on straws
expect more desperation tactics expect
more of this ugliness the exploitation
of tragedy the invective the insults the
horrible smears that's we we have only
entered the 2022 campaign season buckle
up i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the benton shapiro show the
left decides tucker carlson is
responsible for a racist mass shooting
in buffalo liz cheney slanders the gop
as complicit in white supremacy and the
biden administration tries to tax its
way out of inflation as today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen